ينورنا في الاستوديو والزميل العزيز طالب
كنعان اول مذيع واول وجه يطل على شاشه
العربيه في الثالث مارس 2003 دكتور طالب
اهلا بك اهلا وسهلا
انا انسان كائن
بيطلع بس هلال انتم بدور يعني طيب دكتور
في مثل هذا اليوم
في الثانيه ظهرا تحديدا انطلقت قناه
العربيه وكنت اول وجه يقدم نشره اخباريه
فيها كيف كان شعورك تلك اللحظه لكن هي
افضل لحظه او من افضل لحظات في حياتي
واعلن ان مساها مداحيه
بتنتبني مشاعر مختلفه لما بتذكر هذه
اللحظه وخصوصا هلا لما عم ينعرض الفيديو
لما بتشوفي حالك من 20 سنه
بترجع لالك الذاكره الى ذلك الوقت بتعرفي
مرات الذاكرات يعني اذا انت بدك تتذكري
شيء
الذكريات حزينه بطبعه ليه لانه حتى لو
كانت حلوه لانه راحت بدك انت تخطفيها
وترجعيها خلاص راحت واذا كانت حزينه هي
حزينه بطبعه لما بتتذكريها
بتنتابك هذه المشاعر المختلفه
لحظه لن انساها مداحيه لحظه فارقه بحياتي
على المستوى الشخصي وعلى المستوى المهني
تحدي كبير طبعا لانه انا كنت من الاصغر
سنا اذا بدك في البندق الرعيل يعني نحن عم
نحكي انا انضميت الى العربيه بسبتمبر 2002
سبتمبر 2002 يعني بدي اقول لك
شيء اسمه عربيه
وكنا في مرحله تجهيزات وتحضيرات يعني كنا
نقوم الساعه الخامسه صباحا ونجي الفريق
بده يعمل لانه نحن بدنا نطلع بدنا نطلع
يعني ضلينا ريهيرسل من سبتمبر لثلاثه
فكمان بهذا اليوم اطلقت اسعد الله صباحكم
بكل خير وصارت اسعد الله اوقاتكم صباحك
ههه صار عقلي بالصباح بنقول صباح العربيه
اسعد الله صباحكم بس انا بدي اقول سر
للمشاهدين انه طالب من 20 سنه من اول ظهور
له عم يستعمل نفس الايربيس انا بدي اسالك
ليش
احنا كل اسبوعين بدنا نغيرها
عم اقول لك يعني
في بيت شعر للمتنبي بقول خلقت الوفا لو
رجعت الى الصبا لفارقت شيبي موجع القلب
باكيه يعني حتى بيقولوا حتى رجعك للشباب
بقول لك لا لفت الشيء القير فيس من عشرين
سنه او من 21 سنه يعني سبتمبر او ديسمبر
لما اجوا عملوا لنا صبوا لنا على الاذن
هذا الايربيس فصبوا لي انا على اذني
اليمين فاحتفظت فيها وما زلت احتفظ فيها
منذ 21 سنه
ولن اتخلى عنها وهي بتضل معي ممكن يعني في
كتير امور تتغير طيب دكتور يعني نتحدث عن
عشرين عاما العالم تغير وكبت وعصرت العديد
من الاحداث العديد من المواقف هل في مواقف
معينه لساتها راسخه لما بتشتغلي انت بقناه
بحجم العربيه
وعم تشتغلي بمنطقه يعني تسكن الجغرافيا
القلقه من العالم يعني الشرق الاوسط بس
انت تطلعي لوراء يعني تم حرب جرت في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط في العشر سنوات الماضيه
لتعرفي قديش في احداث هائله وانت قناه
اخباريه 24 على 24 ساعه لتشوفي قديش في
احداث
بالاكثر حدث مثلا
يعني بيرجعني بالذاكره وقت انطلاق العربيه
هو دخول القوات الامريكيه الى ساحه
الفردوس واسقاط تمثال رئيس العراقي السابق
صدام حسين وبالطريقه اللي تم يعني حطوا له
علم امريكا انا مش ما بدناش نحكي سياسي بس
انه كنت يومها على الهواء عم غطي وعم شوف
هذا المشهد
كمان حرب تموز في في لبنان وفاه الرئيس
الفلسطيني ياسر عرفات لما جابوه على رام
الله يعني
اضافه الى احداث اخرى يعني ما يسمى احداث
الربيع العربي
اختيار الرئيس رفيق الحريري في في في
لبنان
ومؤخرا الانفجار المرفق في بيروت الحرب في
اوكرانيا الزلزال يعني من كم يوم شوفي
هالمشاهد قديش مؤثره بس يعني طالب وانت عم
تحكي ذكرت كتير احداث انت غطيتها وقطعك
قطعت عليك طوال 20 سنه لتغير عليك انت جيت
مذيع بعدين حصلت على الدكتوراه عملت عيله
بعدين طب صار في كثير امور متغيرات بحياتك
هل الاولوياتك تغيرت الشغفك حسيت انه
المهنه صارت يعني عم تاخذ منك اكثر من عم
تعطيك
بالمهنه اتركيها طالما في بقلبك شغف كملي
فيها وانا بقول دائما ما زال في القلب
متسع لهذه
لهذه المهنه تغير الكثير يعني انا عم اقول
لك لما جينا لهون على العربيه كان فقط
الطابق الاول من المبنى موجود الثاني
والثالث والرابع بعدهم الخامس كان موجود
كان مكاتب يعني كنا يعني
فشوفي قديش
تغير الزمن حتى على مستوى التكنولوجي طب
نحن لما جينا بالالف 2002 ما كان في شيء
اسمه السوشيال ميديا ما في شيء اسمه ثوره
رقميه الان وين بعدين بالالفين واثنين كان
في محطه واحده منافسه وما حطيناش يعني
اكيد يعني
فنحن الان في عندك مئات المحطات الاخباريه
والاف المواقع فكمان انت
لتوجدي نفسك في ظل هذا الكم من المواقع
والقنوات وتسبقي نفسك كمان تتحدي بس حابب
انك تتجه صوب السوشيال ميديا ولا انت لا
مع جماعه
الكلاسيكيه الاخبار شو اللي عملته العربيه
ليش الفرق العربيه ليكي كان في اعلام قبله
يتسم بالتقليد والكلاسيكيه ايش للعربيه
قالت لا يا عمي هذا القالب التقليدي خلينا
نعمل شيء جديد وقلنا للعالم يا عمي بدكم
تحضروا غير محطات حضروها بس تعول عنها
شوفوا عنا جديد الرشاقه يعني عملنا كمان
نحن حتى ثوره ونقله في موضوع الاعلان هلا
من ال2002 للان قديش تطورت وسائل التواصل
التكنولوجيا
العبره كيف انت تعملي ادفيشن سرعه تاقلم
وتكيف مع اللي جرى الحمد لله
اللي ما بيتاقلم بسرعه اللي ما بيتغير
بيتغير هو يعني مشان هيك نحن قدرنا نتاقلم
بشكل سريع مع الثوره الرقميه مع ثوره
مواقع التواصل وبالتالي ضلينا على الساحه
وضلينا من اكثر انتشارا
نورتنا وشرفتنا بصباح العربيه الله يخلي
لنا استاذنا
اسمحولي قبل ما ننهي كمان اشير انه انا
عملت مع دكتور طالب كم من سنه بنشره
المساء انا اتشرف ان تعلمت على ايدك الله
يخليك
بس بتفوق على استاذه
هذا احلى جمله ساعتها اليوم شكرا جزيلا
بدي اقول لكم ينعاد عليكم وبدي اقول
للعربيه كل عام وانت حبيبتي هلا بتزعل
المدام اذا بتطلقني حبيبتي الاولى العربيه
شكرا يا اهلا وسهلا